Build It.
Draw It.
Play It.
Vsauce!
Kevin here with some of the coolest creations
from extraordinary people.
This is BiDiPi.
BUILD IT
Michael Grab assembles sculptures out of rocks
using only gravity.
They’re meant to evoke awe and disbelief
surrounding the forces of nature, as well
as illustrate what can be accomplished with
delicacy and patience.
The series is called Gravity Glue, and you
can watch him assemble the zen garden-like
projects on his YouTube channel.
Shinri Tezuka sculpts intricate animals that
are also lollipops.
Amezaiku is a traditional art from Japan in
which heated taffy is sculpted with tweezers
and scissors and then painted.
The taffy cools within minutes so each piece
must be crafted as efficiently as possible.
Tezuka is the only amezaiku artist in Japan
who uses gradation to color his candy but
he holds classes to teach others his unique
style.
Anish Kapoor built an endlessly churning whirlpool.
The project is called Descension and is meant
to evoke the feelings of discomfort we experience
when confronted with empty spaces.
The first iteration of the project was installed
in India, but in May another one was built
in an abandoned Italian movie theater.
Veronica Richterova repurposes plastic bottles
into plants.
She heats bottles up, carves and attaches
them to other bottles in order to create everything
from colorful cacti to intricate chandeliers.
She has a fascination with plastic, and not
only collects it, but also has written extensively
on its history and usage.
Asuka Dori builds transformer toys out of
candy boxes which is just really cool.
Here’s a caramel box that turns into a
robot, and this horse turns into a tank.
DRAW IT
David Spriggs creates 3D images by layering
sheets of engraved or painted glass.
This piece titled the sun king, depicts a
police officer in riot gear and is based off
of a Roman statue destroyed during the French
revolution.
Spriggs is interested in the relationship
between state power and its faceless enforcers,
which is why the subject is 20 feet tall,
and its face is obscure from every angle.
Xavier paints the desert with light using
light up cacti.
He wanted to create an uncontrollable and
erratic world and then let the viewers interpret
their own personal narrative as they watched
the film.
Find the link below to watch the whole incredible
video.
And now for the organic, globular surrealist
artwork of Jung-Yeon Min.
PLAY IT
Len Solomon is an inventor as well as a one
man orchestra.
He built his majestic bellowphone in 1983,
and it’s comprised of playground balls,
coat hanger wire, vacuum parts and plumbing
pipes.
Dance crews unite to form AXYZM, a company
that specializes in movement design.
Here’s their first video which combines
body movement, props and patterns.
Together Or Alone by Eternal Summers features
stop motion using found objects directed by
Japhy Riddle.
Inspiration also comes from you.
Vsauce Creative Fan Showcase.
First up is Zoo Legacy with She’ll Never
Fall In Love.
Let’s go!
William handcrafts custom stamps on his Etsy
page SublimingSensation.
The versatile stamps work with wood burning,
leather burning, and soap melting.
And he also has a huge variety of custom glass
work.
Janelle creates a wide variety of step by
step nail art tutorials on her YouTube Channel
elleandish.
She creates pop culture characters using nail
stamping as well as making her own stickers
using sandwich bags and templates.
Check out her channel to learn how to do this
and a ton of other stuff.
Here’s Carter with Almost not.
Danielle Sullivan’s Regrowth is an installation
using books to create a garden including flowers,
pebbles and even a shed.
Each item was hand folded and it took two
months to complete.
RubiArt is a collection of friends in Poland
making portraits out of Rubik’s Cubes - including
Marilyn Monroe and a Lion.
Submit your bidipis to BiDiPi@Vsauce.com or
share them with everyone on Twitter with hashtag
BiDiPi.
If you need more inspiration check out Guy’s
show on WEsauce This World Of Ours.
A laidback look at some of the sweetest submissions
by real Vsauce fans.
And as always - thanks for watching.